Ilana, I'm not gonna clean
this man's apartment,
touch his things,
in my underwear.
This is the last
thing, we are so close.
We are gonna be
friends with Weezy.
I'm gonna (bleep) him, dude.
Who's Weezy?
Lil Wayne!
This is
the whole thing!
Listen, it is for one hour
and he's giving us $200.
No, I can't--
This is gross.
What would you be
doing instead?
Watching "Breaking Bad"
and eating a Smart Ones?
Okay, it's a
cashew stir-fry
and I was, like, really
looking forward to it.
I don't want
to hear it, okay.
You're losing your edge and
I wasn't gonna say anything,
but you're not as fun
as you used to be.
Guess I'll clean this
dude's apartment on my own.
(Lil Wayne's
"A Milli" playing)
♪ Yeah
♪ Mack I'm gonna
♪ A millionaire
♪ I'm a Young Money
millionaire ♪
♪ Tougher
than Nigerian hair ♪
♪ My criteria compared to your
career just isn't fair ♪
♪ I'm a venereal disease
like a menstrual bleed ♪
♪ Through the pencil
I leak on the sheet ♪
♪ Of the tablet in my mind
♪ 'Cause I don't write shit
'cause I ain't got time ♪
♪ 'Cause my
seconds minutes hours ♪
♪ Go to the almighty dollar
♪ And the almighty-- ♪
Okay,
hour's up, man.
(Ilana)
Party's over, dude.
Money, please.
I'm sowwy.
I don't have any.
Are you joking
right now?
I'm a wittle baby.
Uh... No, you're a
full grown man.
I'm a baby,
I have no money!
You owe
us $200.
We just cleaned
for an hour.
I don't do
that at my house.
Thank you
for cleaning.
No, no, no.
What?
No thank you.
No, no.
I just degraded
my friend for you
and I thought we were
gonna be paid.
I can pay
you in blocks?
You're not a baby,
you're a man!
No.
I'm a baby.
Oh, yeah...
You're a baby?
Does baby like
this, huh?
♪♪
Babies do not
read books yet!
Are you a baby if
you wear a hat?
Full coat
with fur?
Babies don't have
little... babies!
You want tissues
to wipe your ass(bleep)?
'Cause you're a baby?
(groaning)
Coat racks aren't
for babies.
Marbles.
Uh-oh.
(laughing)
What?
Look.
I'm looking.
Yeah, we saw, dude.
I hope I never see
this again.
I don't
even know.
All right, all right, careful
of the marbles.
So I'm gonna grab this,
'cause babies don't like fur.
Are you my fwends?